مفاصل الدوله العراقيه باتت في يد طهران
يحاول اسماعيل القراني ما لقى فريق قاسم
سليماني وبطريقه ذاتها شبكه واسعه من
العملاء للتغلغلي في مؤسسات العراق
الميليشيات العنوان الابراج وتحديدا الحشد
وانشاء شبكه المهندس التي تحدثنا عنها
الاسبوع الماضي لم يكن الا خطوه واحده على
طريق التمادي فطيران تحاول استغلال غياب
احدى العثرات مصطفى الكاظمي على طلب
المناسبه شركه المهندس وحاول تفادي اقراها
وجود الكاظمي كان مزعجا للطيران خاصه وانه
مكن الاستخبارات من المنافذ الحدوديه
والمطارات ومنع الفصائل من التحكم بها
واغلق غير الرسميه منها
خروج الكاظمي من المعادله السياسيه ارسى
معادله الارتياح امنيا ومليا ايضا اطلاق
يد ايران نحو 80 مليار دولار فائض مالي
سلمه الكاظم للسوداني تريده الطيران
والوسائل كثيره شركه المهندس احداها وشركه
ايمن سوزان وسيله اخرى بمكاتبها في بغداد
وكربلاء الشركتان مرتبطان بشركه ايرانيه
تحدثنا عنها بالامس وعن سيطرتها على مفاصل
الاقتصاد الايراني
سهل وضع يد ايران على مليارات اخرى تشكل
المصدر الثاني للدخل في البلاد بعد النفط
السياحه الدينيه وهنا طريق اخر يحاول فيه
قائم فراغ السليمان طريق اقتصاد العتبات
وهذه محطه في كربلاء عتبه توقف فيها
سليماني ومن بعده عليك هنا انهمك عمال
ايرانيون تابعونا لشركه الكوثر في اكبر
التوسعه للعتبه منذ 300 عام ما لقوا حفره
عمقها 40 مترا ومساحتها 50,000 متر مربع
بالاسياخ الفولاذيه والاسمنت المستورد من
ايران وعلى عكس الكاظمي وجود السوداني وهو
المحسوب على طهران سيدنا هذه المشروعات
الدينيه امتيازات خاصه ومنها اعفاءات
جمركيه على الموارد المستورده من ايران